see oh is the new blog post up let's
let's go i'm gonna refresh it here
yes new blog post is up all right guys
let's uh
switch screens here
and let me take off my camera for a
second
all right hogwarts legacy so this just
went up march 17th your first look at
extended gameplay and again this is by
chandler wood juan's at the ready for
wizarding duels magical beast character
customization and more
lumos hi i'm chandler wood i'm a
slytherin and the community manager here
at avalanche software it's been a while
since we first revealed hogwarts legacy
back then i still hadn't even joined the
studio now i'm part of this incredible
team that has put a ton of effort into
making sure our gameplay reveal would be
worth the wait we couldn't be more
excited that it's finally here we've all
dreamt of receiving our letters
attending hogwarts and forging a legacy
of our own as wizarding world fans we've
wondered what it would be like for our
stories to be found between the pages of
a book because that magic field world
has always felt close to our own
hogwarts legacy is your story rooted
firmly in the wizarding world lore and
it starts with creating the witch or
wizard you want to be here we go we got
a nice little shot here
oh how about all the outfit
customizations and stuff
i love seeing that when you go to uh
hogsmeade
an authentic wizarding world i joined
avalanche in late 2021 but the team had
already been hard at work for many years
i'm still reeling that i get to work on
a project that captures the magic spells
beasts people stories and wonder of the
wizarding world as community manager
it's my pleasure to introduce you to a
development team full of fans making an
authentic wizarding world adventure yeah
let's talk about that authentic word
they
they really kept coming back to
that one of the first things i did was
ask game director alan 2 what fans love
and expect from the wizarding world our
results and conversations could fill
tomes but when i asked him to settle it
into two sentences for me he told me
quote the most ever present part of the
wizarding world is its magic and the
play for nature playful nature and
realness of its distinct rules should
feel a super fuel oh my gosh guys i'm so
excited feel a surprising dark mystery
that tests the combat resources of those
who discover it but just as important
are the opportunities to experience
hundreds of memorable moments
you just say hundreds
small and large that fans grew up with
and know by heart from being sorted in
the great hall which they still didn't
reveal more about sorting they said
you'll be sorted at the beginning of the
game but they didn't they didn't really
tell us how or anything
exploring a new secret chamber in
hogwarts or impersonating others with
polyjuice potion
to projecting in it to protecting
innocence from a dangerous troll dodging
fireballs from a hungarian horntail
excuse me or soaring into the sky on the
back of a friendly hippogriff wait can
we is that all confirmed chandler
are are we confirming paul juice are we
confirming hungarian horntail
let's go dude got a nice little shot
here of them flying over the grounds
all of these elements are imperative to
the experience but at the center of it
all is a fully explorable hogwarts
is it replete
replete with secrets to discover and
mysteries to unravel to learn more about
our version of hogwarts i had to go to
an expert hogwarts environmental lead
boston madsen has lived the life of a
huge harry potter fan she knows the
books inside and out a crucial resource
when it comes to designing a hogwarts
that can embrace feelings of both
familiarity and discovery
love that
quote we built the hogwarts we as fans
ourselves wanted to explore boston said
i think anyone who has read the books
whether they are an artist or not has
built a version of hogwarts in their
heads right yeah definitely despite this
being our version of hogwarts that's
important to remember too guys right
their version of hogwarts so it's okay
if some things are a little different uh
what matters is like the spirit you know
staying true to the spirit of of that
hogwarts it's a world you'll instantly
recognize there are familiar haunts like
the great hall clock tower and hospital
wing but also completely new places like
the bustling kitchens
well that's not really new i guess we
just never we just never saw it up close
as much in the books boston said having
felt like a student in these halls
myself the development of this game i
can honestly say there are still areas i
come across that i didn't know about
before
what
oh that's awesome
that is awesome yeah that's totally
peeves guys peeps confirmed let's go
beyond just architecture and design i've
been consistently amazed at how much our
hogwarts feels that's what i was talking
about man that's the main thing feels
like the magical school i've always
wanted to attend including
extracurricular activities like avoiding
peace while sneaking into the restricted
section of the library life at hogwarts
is as much about finding secret chambers
and sneaking into the prefect's bathroom
as it is learning to cast spells and
brew potions depending on which hogwarts
house you're in you'll get to see each
common room's distinct architecture
decor and entrances depending on which
hogwarts house you're in
can we sneak around though can we sneak
into the other ones or not my fellow
slytherins will be particularly fond of
our common room entrance vanishing into
a wall behind the slithering body of an
enormous stone serpent we're also
excited to show you our takes on the not
often seen ravenclaw and hufflepuff
common rooms ravenclaws rest high in a
tower while hufflepuffs reside in a cozy
basement expect more in-depth looks at
the common rooms later this year
more info yes thank you they're not just
gonna go completely dark now
i can hardly tear myself away from
exploring the castle but this game goes
well beyond the walls of hogwarts to
explore the village of hogsmeade and the
surrounding countryside hogsmeade is
home to enchanting new characters with
rich stories and personalities of their
own as well as vendors who will provide
supplies you need for your schooling and
other adventures
part of the magic of hogwarts legacy is
exploring familiar locations in a new
light like just how close hogsmeade is
to hogwarts or seeing the forbidden
forest in the daylight but to really
offer a sense of freedom we wanted to
expand the scope of what you know about
the land surrounding the castle we
wanted you to have new locations to
discover to see what lies around and
beyond the black lake to meet new
witches and wizards in the dwellings
that dot the landscape beyond hogsmeade
and learn what other undiscovered
chambers lie
within hogwarts or scattered across the
scottish highlands alan told me
a little shot of the niffler there
as game developers we've labored over
maintaining authenticity while making
sure the game is still a fun experience
that's a tough challenge you know that's
that's not easy to do there were
hundreds of choices that had to be made
between lore and gameplay and even some
of the differences between each film and
book allen said although we wanted to
present a new interpretation of the
wizarding world for gamers and
prioritized a fun game before book or
film authenticity
describing it this way can never capture
how exhaustively we strive for
authenticity and immediate recognition
in everything we did
this is a long blog post all right live
the unwritten here
in many ways
your legacy in the late 1800s wizarding
world will be familiar to everything you
loved about the harry potter series
discovering magic making new friends and
being a hero
narrative lead
moira squire
offered me some insight into these
parallels
players will get to experience what it
was like for harry starting at a new
wizarding world school and knowing no
one at all and like harry the player's
character is a bit of a celebrity
from the outset due to the fact that
they are starting as a fifth year and
because they survived a
what
sorry moira no spoilers let's just say
your arrival to hogwarts is rather
eventful
there we go a little bit more
information on that i wonder i hope it's
not a killing curse
i hope it's not a killing curse
but maybe it is who knows i i bet it's
something to do with uh
oh man what would it be though like what
would it be that would
so it's it's something that warranted
news in the wizarding world
interesting all right your ties to an
ancient magic put you on a collision
course with a goblin rebellion led by
ran rock we heard them mention his name
in the trailer i think aided by his
alliance with the dark wizard victor
rookwood who both present formidable
threats to the entire wizarding world
ran rock has seen a glimmer of a magic
that wizard kind tried to hide even from
themselves and he wants that power in
particular his world view is skewed by
his hatred of wizards which makes his
alliance with victor rookwood
particularly tenuous moira said once
ranrock gets what he wants no one will
be able to stop him and the wizarding
world will be doomed
to unearth the mysteries behind ancient
magic and stop ran rocks rebellion
you'll need a friend and mentor to guide
you along the way enter professor
eleazar fig
oh they're only spelling it with one g
so perhaps
no relation because i'm pretty sure
arabella fig was two g's
or maybe they just took creative
liberties with that i don't know whose
investigations into rumors of a goblin
rebellion have earned him an uneasy
skepticism from the ministry of magic
hey we know all about that
is just one of the many characters who
will play a part in your journey whether
it's fellow students becoming companions
professors teaching you new spells or
even some assistance from those who
reside outside the hogwarts walls
there's no shortage of friendly faces to
provide a helping hand or a welcome
distraction you may even come across
some familiar names like a weasley or
two
oh
weasley's confirmed weasleys in the game
wow i'm surprised at how much they're
confirming here in this define your
combat style your studies at hogwarts
will help you overcome the mysteries and
dangers that lurk beyond and even within
the walls of the castle as you learn
from your professors and classmates
you'll gain new spells and abilities to
use in combat and puzzles throughout
hogwarts legacy
alright moving on down here a variety of
spells provides different ways to
approach combat do you go in wands
blazing by using accio to pull an enemy
close before blasting them with incendio
or do you cast the disillusionment charm
to take a stealthier approach finishing
off enemies with a silent petrificus
totalis takedown different techniques
will be required to counter enemy
strengths and weaknesses that should
make every encounter feel engaging
interesting i'm hoping they also have it
wide enough to where there are some
encounters you can approach however you
want
as a gamer who likes a bit of a
challenge myself i'm happy to say that
we've been working hard to make sure
combat and hogwarts legacy has a depth
and challenge for players who want it
whether you just want to experience the
story or make every swish and flick of
your wand matter a range of difficulty
options will be available to meet
various skill levels enabling players to
experience the game in a way most
enjoyable to them
alright so from software fans
or i should say from software haters
don't worry they're going to be
difficulty options in
anyone familiar with the wizarding world
knows that magic goes beyond just one
work magical plants and potions bring
even more tools to each fight you'll be
able to brew wigginweld potions for
healing and use a mandrake seedling to
incapacitate enemies with its cry as you
continue your studies at hogwarts you'll
learn more recipes for potions and how
to handle an assortment of magical
plants
wow this is a long blog
which incredible we're gonna have to
read this multiple times too
uh a single player action rpg our
hogwarts legacy state of play
presentation showed quite a few other
things the room of requirement taming
magical beasts customizable gear that
you can loot and earn throughout the
world and a whole lot more yes it did
chandler yes it did we'll be diving into
many of these topics in detail before we
launch
yes thank you however there is one more
thing i wanted to make sure we addressed
plainly oh oh here we go here we go
hogwarts legacy is a single player open
world action
rpg there you go guys i think i think
they're saying
this is them saying okay we hear you on
the multiplayer but not happening not
happening while you can have npc
companions join you on your adventures
the story is about your own legacy these
are only pieces of the immense
experience we're building in hogwarts
legacy game director allen 2 best sums
up how everything comes together
here we go
with hogwarts legacy we had the
incredible opportunity to tell any story
we wanted within the wizarding world one
fantasy stood out many fans of harry
potter imagined what it would be like to
receive their own hogwarts letter be
sorted and attend hogwarts more than
anything else we wanted to allow fans
after all these years to finally tell
their story their way at the most
beloved school of witchcraft and
wizardry only an open world action rpg
could capture the breadth of our
fantasies i agree with them actually
your story deserves to be as thrilling
as other wizarding heroes we start you
as a late fifth year so you needn't hold
back on the kinds of adventures and
themes you might want to explore
we place you in the 1800s to ensure your
legend is never overshadowed by any
other hero and we invent a new dark
mystery so your conflict never feels
like a retread of something you've seen
before love that too with your continued
support we hope to explore even more in
the future
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait do
you guys realize what this means
do you guys realize what this mean this
this right here
may be the most important line of this
whole entire post
this may be the most important line of
the entire post with your continued
support we hope to explore even more in
the future
i mean dlc is my first thought
sequel is my next thought
absolutely
that
oh my gosh okay last paragraph
we are honored to have been entrusted
with the freedom to create a brand new
wizarding world experience for fans
around the world as a fan and gamer
myself i can't wait to talk more with
you throughout the year about the
incredible experience hogwarts legacy
will bring to wizarding world fans and
gamers alike from all of us here at
avalanche software we hope you enjoyed
this look at the game and we can't wait
to show you more
soon
boy
all right that was a lot of reading but
that was a
plethora of information an absolute
plethora of information
wow i mean there's a lot there again i
think the most important line was that
one at the end
um but i do think i do think that was
chandler
understanding his role as a community
manager when he was saying the part
about single player i think they've
definitely heard us those who wanted
some form of co-op those who wanted some
form of multiplayer i think that was him
saying we hear you guys not happening
with this game like
single player open world action rpg
that's what we're focused on
so some people are going to be thrilled
by that some people are probably going
to be kind of upset by that i'm okay
with it i just always kind of had this
hunch this thought that maybe there is
multiplayer gonna be in there um but
yeah i think that's that's pretty much
him saying no
no
which you know i appreciate that's
that's the kind of communication we've
been
wanting and hoping for right so i
appreciate that
maybe like mass effect oh dude jay ross
could you imagine did you imagine if
like it gets to a point where our
character we get to continue them on
but at the bare minimum i think that was
hinting at dlc i really do
um with your support see that's like
that's like saying you guys gotta
support the game if people don't buy it
then it's not gonna happen
but
i don't know about you guys but uh
i think people are gonna buy this game
i think they're gonna buy the game
i really do